good to see you Mike it's our guide
Jamal Murray like we said making history
for consecutive hold on NBA Finals
Jamal we've talked earlier this season
right about how great you were in 2020
during a run when you got hurt and then
to see the way you play now it's like
you've evolved into being a guy that can
get Genesis in four consecutive games
how much pride do you take in that
creating for others not just getting
your own buckets
um
um just not fighting it you know uh they
felt like they're a blitzed me all game
you know just basically trying to live
in my my shot attempts
um and I wasn't fighting it we knew that
if they do that we're playing four on
three in the backside and then we're
gonna that guy step up and make shots so
you know like I said guys we're cutting
guys were moving and um so I guess it's
tough to guard all of us you can't
some one or two guys you gotta account
for everybody else on the floor and that
makes it
um us tough to guard you know everyone
talks about you know your your physical
toughness I want to speak to you about
your your mental toughness and your
Collective mental toughness as a
basketball team how has that grown and
evolved over the last couple of years
for all of you individually and then
collectively as a team and everyone
talks about the physical
but what we're seeing now is the mental
toughness that you guys are showing not
only the toughness but the intellect
that you're playing with uh yeah I mean
the Mind carries the body you know so if
you put your mind to something whatever
it is uh the body's gonna give yourself
up to follow so I think not just me but
we all did a great job of just you know
honing in getting our treatment focusing
what we got to do not worrying about the
crowd uh keeping Our poise on the road
um and for me just uh you know that that
gets me going no pain gets me going so
um just staying locked in and having fun
out there you know putting your body to
the test is always uh always fun this
team reminds me a lot of the San Antonio
Spurs with the Tim Duncan era guys in
this regard I asked manoji globally and
this is the question for you
how difficult was it because I've
watched you play AAU when you were
coming into the states
obviously at Kentucky going on
knowing that you can score so easily
because every time you get the ball you
say I could score and I said this to
Ginobili every time you get it you feel
you have the advantage but how do you
decide
that that four on three like you said is
on the back side when do you decide to
say I'm not going to take advantage of
the advantage that I think I have every
time I touch the ball uh I'm just
picking my spots I think I
um throughout the game you know it's
gonna be a long game you know so it may
not be my quarter I may not shoot for
six seven minutes may not touch it but
as long as we're winning the game and I
haven't got going yet then we're in a
good spot you know so it's about picking
my spots and
um keeping pressure on them from all
areas of the court and today you know a
guy stepped up and made shots they made
my job easy just finding the open man um
final man so we got one more and um it's
a team game everybody came in today
stepped up and uh we're just having fun
right now talk to me about your
relationship with Coach Malone I mean
you two seem to have a very special
relationship where you know it's it
seems to go beyond just coach player it
seems to be a lot of care and tenderness
in that relationship
um well he knows how much I love the
game and um
he trusts me out there you know we've
only Built trust in the seven years that
we've been together he's seen me
obviously only seven seven that that
that's unheard of in the NBA the new NBA
for sure right right well we've had our
core together you know what I'm saying
so we we kind of know what we're looking
for or know where to get our shots from
um he knows when I got to go in it's
more of a feel it's like it's less X's
and O's it's more of what's your move
like today you know what I'm saying so
um I think that's where I stems from
yeah 2018. I'm with Minnesota you're
with Denver cooking
I'm about to get to it the last game of
the season both of us are fighting for a
playoff spot yeah it comes down to us
too unique situation me and him have
some words in the game
afterwards I'm like I like him he's a
dog he tears his ACL I reach out to you
I say You're Gonna Come Back better than
ever
did you believe during those hard
moments of hard days of tearing the ACL
that you would get back to this moment
that you prepare for this moment yeah
yeah it took uh it took a I'd say it
took a good month and a half
once I start seeing Improvement I was
like okay
I'm seeing this much improvement already
I know that by the time I'm ready to go
I'll be ready
um
but I just for me it's like I wanna I
was motivated like I want to be I want
to jump higher I want to be able to jump
left right I want to jump two foot vert
like a g you know what I'm saying so
um just having that in my mind like
motivated motivated me to lift more on
my bad days
um and just stay locked in throughout it
you know because you know you you got to
rehab you have those days where like I
don't want to do it I want to do it but
then that hurts you at this time yeah
yeah I was
busting my ass for a good six seven
months straight like I didn't want to do
it but I'm doing extra just because I
know that we're gonna need me at this
time and
um it's paying off you say paying off
one win away from winning your first NBA
championship how you feeling about that
one more staying even kill we can talk
after that's that Kobe answer job's not
finished job's not done
anything else for Jamal Murray good luck
brother tell your dad I'll meet him at
our spot okay I saw the cooking I saw a
couple of my moves you displaying too at
the Jamal thing oh yeah all right we're
happy for you
thank you appreciate it
Jamal Murray and the Denver Nuggets
again just a single win away from the
first NBA Championship in franchise
history